hey guys how's it going so I'm here with
Cassie and today we are gonna be doing
the easy challenge the shishi challenge
yeah you texted me I was like okay what
do you do after he spinners I've seen so
many youtubers do this over the course
of the ten years that I've been on the
internet making videos and I've never
done Oh
so this is gonna be our first time yeah
so we've got two chairs off back here so
we're gonna spin ourselves and then
you're gonna give us some yoga poses to
do okay yes but I've never done yoga
after spitting myself so this could be
interesting and our first one is this
one that is great let's spin and then do
it okay how long were you sitting for
like 15 seconds okay and if you close
your eyes I don't know oh boy oh oh whoa
whoa philia mystic point okay she's a
longer yeah yeah great what if the first
one I think was so much that was an easy
one good job but I do feel dizzy doggy
now definitely felt whirly okay let's
see our next move
oh this is gonna be hard okay actors
post Wow alright okay this is so yeah
oh okay okay to do this normally wait oh
my god I feel nauseous have all those
right just spin me around it's not fun
no that's a fun okay oh this could be
interesting
thirty Seconds okay we keep occupied
you're gonna outfit cuz Robo retriever
yes okay
[Music]
[Applause]
for summer is the Sun is heating up but
everything is spinning like it's very
okay oh yeah focus on that one spot oh
oh God okay does not feel good it
doesn't but I do want to like I don't
know
hi this is a bad idea we should go okay
Oh God oh this is the dumbest idea for
heat alliteration I'm here I just feel
like real dizzy
I feel sick see you really know I know
okay where you going okay yeah should we
do 40 signs are you set for voice I can
I can do 40 seconds okay are you 46 okay
directions scallops
[Music]
wait hold on okay yeah I don't really
give see what are you doing oh great
okay well done how do you feel feel like
I actually just did a workout oh yeah
just fun around the chair I wanna burn
extra calories so this is really
fortress it was I would not recommend
this at all if you feel like you might
emotions oh thank you so much for
watching the dizzy fitness challenge I
sure did sure dizzy yoga challenge but
we survived did I feel nauseous
but okay you did good thank you okay
thank you guys mr. Casas channel and see
our fun little video that we did and she
also has tons of amazing fitness videos
and I actually done from your workout
for Justine come of it she killed me but
it in a good way
yeah anyway always good oh yeah wow that
is that's not fun not a fireable at home
you're doing a challenge with I just see
yeah I'm so excited this is gonna be so
fun and this is the very first episode
of testing